Let's say n is 4, so we have x1 plus x2 all the way to x4 has to equal 10.
Let's choose a number, any number. I like the number 13. What does this mean?
That means that x2 plus x3 plus x4 has to equal 10 minus 13, so it has to equal
negative 3. Okay, let's pick another number. I like the number 8. So, so far
we've chosen that x1 is 13, x2 is 8. This means that x3 plus x4 equals negative
3 minus 8, which is negative 11. We can still choose another value for x3 or
x4. I like the number three so let's say x3 is 3 and now what is that mean, x4
must equal negative 11 minus 3 which is negative 14, so x4 has been forced, but
I was able to choose these three, there were four numbers to start out with and
I have three degrees of freedom. If we have n numbers, we have n minus 1
degrees of freedom. Good job!